[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes un bon chef de bande
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai nom
céréales si si si si je vous le dis
elles y sont moins turbulent l'emea bah
ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'est la légion
coup droit et cissé sont très graves
outre la vision j'espère qu'un jour vous
serez voilà ce sur sur s'est vite c'est
un c'est un de mes rêves
voila voila mais ça na san san se
concrétise j'avais vous avez signé sur
la dans le groupe m6 l'année prochaine
et je sais qu on flirte beaucoup si on
met jamais la langue quoi d'ailleurs
vous avez bien lu pour garder sur moi
regardez il ya un truc que regarder
avant de se quitter regarder eric
naulleau ce qu'il a dit que si reach est
pas ce qui se passe on s'adore mais ouf
leur nom mais jamais la langue on
consomme jamais c'est notre côté [ __ ]
à toulouse on n'arrête pas de sa mini
n'en consomment jamais un moment il faut
conclure ça va se faire mais ça va se
faire ça va c'est la faire arrêter les
slows et les petites feuilles à lille va
falloir qu'on fasse exactement
et même si vous montez sur scène toi tu
monte sur scène avec angie rapport à mai
paquin et à bayonne
kabila reconnaît parmi nos vieux amis la
ilaha illa très relaxant merci et bonne
action
j'ai jamais eu je prends pas les axes
n'ai jamais eu d'action pour les absents
mais en fait la question quand tu as un
enfant tu te prépares aller dans la vie
tu lui apprend à marcher
zai toi son père en td est ce que tu lui
a appris à marcher est ce qu elle peut
se lancer seul
voilà c'est toi qui dois la répression
et je vais la donner après je vais
donner mon avis aussi à eric soir éric
mallet en tout cas là tout son or et
interviewer et rêver voilà c'est ça
c'est sûr il fallait en garder de
répondre ouais sommaire